hey guys Greg it's John happy Mother's
Day to all you people out there who were
born from a vagina or c-section now you
got a mom
grab her give her a hug I'm going to do
a video with Amber placer right now but
I got John here with me to talk about
something special we just launched some
t-shirt t-shirt take a look at this
stuff cause you guys have been asking
for shirts for about a couple years now
my sister ex Mary black X on Instagram
please go ahead and follow her too did
these design back here and she has a
bunch of really cool pictures up on her
Instagram right now look at my sick ones
inspired by the movie Drive to get it
but it's me it's Ryan coupling this one
right here and you guys remember Ryan
right do we designed this picture ages
ago
but now you can have a ride right shirt
inspired by the distaff used AI you just
can't let go to the past Oh what do I
say whenever a trailer is good John dip
will know they're gonna go there's the
one I like to call her super bad one
even though it doesn't look like the
cover is super bad I just think it's
super bad for some reason and of course
you know we're told the real rejects and
where do we get our titled inspire from
Oh a movie called one of our mutual
favorite movies The Devil's Rejects
written and directed by Roberto zona me
there's me as Captain Spaulding as John
is Otis and we're the only ones that run
the channel so you know we don't have a
female to put there for you guys keep an
eye on the source there gonna be more
stuff in it there's going to be more -
sobbing - didn't what I'm those on
alright I gotta go do a video hot water
ugh with Amber get out of here okay and
I'm gonna change my shirt because we
shot it on a different day
hello rejects especially the ones in the
Philippines
I'm Greg Alba I'm an Atlantic abre
plaster from the amber plaster Channel
afterbuzz TV and and other thing other
things around what what do people think
we talk in this weird cadence and
off-camera we always talk like this this
is when the camera is on we deliver
lines I mean words you want to know
they're like this like this see a long
time ago because you did one of these
filipino commercials with me yeah we
film the Filipino person we did one of
these but it started with one thing
called jollibee and jollibee has the
most intense commercials and i saw three
of them and i by never bald like on a
commercial like i did for those this is
new one outfits Mother's Day you have a
mother yes I do too
she's the Filipino one so this video was
dedicated to the patron of the day Joyce
album oh I love that I'm half Filipino
so I only say Filipino words half right
tango let's watch it's only two and a
half minutes can't be that sad yeah we
can handle it you can handle it yeah bro
yeah bro I know [ __ ] got it
[Music]
restroom in tyrannical teabagger
production unavailable the litigation
Quran island down the last 72 days loss
of life two phenomena Diane scenic level
of Omaha night in Phoenix Arizona
mr. Bobby
[Music]
you opponent guidance as well as
resources incarnations of meanings of
enough that what you learn when we get a
local and hopefully we begin the
delivery
[Music]
Pagoda possible monopsony endovenous
okay son so Joey era began in gonna toss
a yo-yo
and it will this will be deserving that
we get it was ha ha ha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's really touching
[Music]
[ __ ] jolly we're here no we got to go
after this Oh
[Music]
hell yeah yeah man hell yeah
happy Mother's Day I didn't ask where
but okay why not even have to speak for
my mom just for my mom I won't bleep
that up
I never your mouth this is like mom you
know I'm so happy that video went from
here's the setup and it just plays out
how you want it to be the other Jollibee
commercials I know you haven't seen them
I always have this setup and then it
takes a random turn and it makes you
heartbroken I was kind of expecting her
like not be there I thought she's going
to be like that or something yeah I kept
expecting the worst kids sort of harder
like oh she's dead she definitely did
but she's around this reminds me a lot
of my mom for sure my mom a Filipino
they got that in common that's the
number one plus B mom was the
breadwinner and drove enough machine
she's the a she still is
mom always provided financially even
when we were struggling she would be
that person going to the school having
to talk to them about okay how can we
make sure my son can stay in school you
know like she worked her ass off she was
the problem solver when it came to
anything like that dad passed away still
takes care of me I love that woman you
can relate to this literally yeah I can
and when I went an Oscar for sound
design because that's my passion
I'm going to put the Oscar around her
neck when I get offstage shopping to be
in your golden shiny shoes yeah she will
make that it was perfect for Mother's
Day even when I was a child actor she
paid for my headshots covered all the
gas my auditions you know she still
takes care of me no I love this [ __ ] out
of my mom yeah you see the Filipino
woman her tough woman yeah that's one
thing I noticed about that it's rarely
you're like you're a lazy Filipino woman
I did I really see that there's not
something
I know if you have I come from a strong
line of grandma and a mom the Filipino
women are very they're hard workers and
they're loyal they take care there's
even something going on right now where
a lot of times women from the
Philippines come get jobs in America so
they can send money back to their family
with a dad like taking care of the kids
and one Philippine yeah I don't really
know like the full details that I've
only heard a little bit about that
either women have more luck getting jobs
or than the menu
maybe maybe clear meditated a Filipino a
little I'd like to date a Filipino woman
you should I think I should you should
honor your heritage in that way I should
continue on the legacy
if you can't really can yes as I got my
Italian side but let's just face it we
just love to eat a lot of high
cholesterol food and we're very angry
people and a lot of Italians yeah
there's plenty of Italian is nothing
unique nothing Union we need to create
more Filipinos Jim in California
especially in California I mean we have
Filipino town I don't like a lot people
live but I know that my mom didn't get
Jollibee for us all the time was seeing
what they were doing we're going out to
get bastard and stuff because we didn't
have money growing up yeah so we would
get food it was like it was like Burger
King or McDonald's and it did remind me
of that I'm like after graduation I
could see us doing like a fast-food
place
yes I remember even elbows every Easter
Sunday after Mass we would go get
mcdonalds breakfast so this is
reminiscent is this really is like yeah
this is very accurate if I don't I'm
gonna get on stage one I forgot that you
were a Catholic yeah
kill I'm a Satanist don't forget that
yeah piercing it's like their worship
Trump yeah yeah we went to a lot of fast
food places and like treat a bit like a
meal out yeah and like sat down in the
restaurant at Lakeville taco and
chick-fil-a and had like a Sunday lunch
there and like you don't have much money
but you want tasty quantity yeah yeah I
know about that
oh it's awesome I should buy her flowers
you should she like wait does she like
flowers no my mom is one of those people
that when she it takes a lot for her to
get emotional to get truly emotional
well did you gather sarcastic or telling
me what I should do in my taxes because
this would like to do of eight things
my name is under a lot of her stuff but
like our insurance I her cell phone
bills like all connected to the family
and so she's always on top of me about
payments because I tend to be late I
tend to be like ah crap forgot a factor
that's Martin every once in a while my
mom and I have a really good like every
like couple years we have it's really
good like cry that's good yeah it's
funny way to I'm on credit money same
yeah you sure it's probably cheese balls
in front of it
or maybe just get her something I so you
think that sure like and then cheap
internet doesn't work - my mom used to
love Mel Gibson I'm sorry is all about
my mom and nothing a my god
well Mel Gibson kind of changes image a
little bit over the years I was allowing
it because my family feel like worships
Mel Gibson but my mom is anyway so I
could totally get along with your family
I love Mel Gibson I like the way you
said it was super easy no hey hey we'll
go see Tom Richards cool I should be
your family because I love Mel Gibson
I've been an active supporter of his
comeback for many years now let's not
get into it let's I gonna get my mom at
her office one time she had a birthday
party I think it was a surprise birthday
party coworker sued for her and they
they put up a bunch of photos of no
gifts in threw out her office
Oh would like a bunch of quotes of like
hey Julie send some funny lines and I
complimented her I like that you get a
rimmel Gibson book I don't think she
appreciates that anymore because I've
even also know guest her like I don't
think so no she does I think he's ruined
that okay for her here to find a very
good crush then it's five some guys like
CBS or ahead an NBC show
just get her like an emcee
that's like this [ __ ] you wash it like
NCAA episode or the like it is that is
the eye candy yeah what do you know I I
am like who watch oh oh and if
demographics like my Bahamas perfect so
I feel like the younger generation like
us is more into like these great cable
shows yeah or some edgy CW show or
something
no like what is it no network network
right yeah my first cable so network is
all for like the parents yeah yeah I
mean the minimum of course is like huge
shows on network channels and Molly is
left foot but I feel like those shows
like NCIS long order that's my mom right
there yeah procedural blueblood yeah
comment below and let us know how real
your parents are but with less or NCIS
yeah is there anything you want to say
to your mom on Mother's Day happy
Mother's Day
thanks for putting up with me I've been
no word no I was super argumented as a
kid um believe it or not it to my mom
and like my mom is like really late just
like soft-spoken but like really
stubborn so it was a good mixture I see
where you get it from that yeah so like
she so essentially rates on the
grandmother I'm sorry to just describe
yourself so did I really have spoken a
little stubborn well I'm not soft-spoken
I think you might be confusing my self
is a gentle way of talking little family
yeah go rest what I heard is yeah good I
have a new voice um but I'll take that
so that's that's better
and I normally never like a soft raspy
voice off brass just like a slow claw is
what I do mama
ah this is about mothers let's circle
back I was
I was raised with my grandmother and and
she was wonderful she was super old
school and and I needed that because I
was super rebellion though it was good
for me and I am very grateful to be
raised by the woman that I was because a
weaker woman would not have worked
let me tell you when you were born were
you pushed out of the vagina over USC
Section vagina nice yeah I'm a c-section
that was first born gotcha
you didn't smoke or anything for me
other kids can't say Tuesday she was a
real precious with me she liked markdown
like me first sight of food and
everything in a book and all my brothers
have like no pictures of them right yeah
I'm not gonna look back it is keep us
with the wide with handouts I yet my mom
for her like when I was really going
what constantly tell me about the scar
she has in her stomach and how it was my
fault I would know that's clearly
clearly mine she willingly win against
birth control in most cases I would
Catholic so to believe in birth control
well minister thought she I was rolling
around in her stomach and the cord got
wrapped her on my neck I'm [ __ ] so my
heart kept stopping and they were like
we have to perform in a mutiny
pretty sure I'm Toby bit you really I
don't know that means I'm trying to
think about it what's up no no think so
so they had to perform an immediate
emergency c-section she said that she
had to stay on all fours the gound and
they had to wheel her to like another
other side of the hospital so she had to
like stay on her ass hanging out thank
God for the c-section
it was all my fault anyhow you labor
sounds terrifying
no it's not be a man about it any bad
you know that's not for me not for me
it's just terrifying but I respect any
woman that has been through that process
willingly or otherwise because holy crap
even if you get a c-section it's not a
walk in the park because you're like
your muscles get cut and they don't like
really return only no they don't and you
need your muscles in your stomach took
off and like swallow and take up and
yeah quickly feel like your breathing
gets affected when you have a c-section
and they just staple your stomach back
together yeah like just a few staples on
it and they'll just eventually join
again the recovery is is real yeah she
took care of me though that woman my
hair my mom had four c-sections after me
whoa
my mom's a trooper yeah it's pressuring
shooting in them I seriously I don't
yeah
she's still hot yes oh yeah I I feel
like my mom was pretty set on having
children she that's what she wanted to
like you know I mean like tell ya that
was like her life goal yeah my mom
always wanted kids I think yeah when she
came into Philippines in the 80s and
then my handsome white father oh yeah he
was a teacher she was a student and they
did just like in a fairy tale just like
in the fairy tale Hey
happy Mother's Day to everyone on
Tuesday extra low conversation for you
guys dear mothers and parents for those
of you who don't have Mother's thank you
for putting up with us we love you and
we don't tell you thank you enough oh
definitely I'd up I tell my mom thank
you like like once a month and that's
what she does like 15 things kind of
rejects briefly like the base rail go
over there join the Patriot community
got LA take her to the day shout-out yay
you know who you know who became a
patron member my brother jab eco a he is
part of the patreon community now I am
not part of him
I should probably reciprocate auditors
that predict how it's a fair trade
I should do like like less than half the
amount that he contributed his older
Kees older yeah so you should be saying
Kim Chi taken care of you I think you
should have I believe it's like a really
organs responsible you take care of my
little brothers and I feel like I'm
always the one giving them gifts they
don't give me
and I'm just like no because you can see
my baby thank you I give my brother
shoutouts to his channel once in a while
that's my chick that's what you get
little brother that's what she get also
ever plasters on the amber blaster
shadow at the channel go check it out
she is a rootin tootin good time and she
is on afterbuzz TV on all the segments
she's a star fish might as well just
called amber buzz TV and that's not true
but I do different TV show reactions on
that supposed to be behind and right now
I'm doing things in love and up next is
a winner hurt anything else no did I cut
you off
don't stress you forget in the video all
in this video all this videos so hard
you won't even know what happened happy
Mother's Day